- [Presenter] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
We are the paradoxical ape; bipedal,
naked, large brain. Long the master of
fire, tools and language, but still trying
to understand ourselves. Aware that death
is inevitable yet filled with optimism. We
grow up slowly. We hand down knowledge. We
empathize and deceive. We shape the future
from our shared understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts from diverse
disciplines to exchange insights on who we
are and how we got here. An exploration
made possible by the generosity of humans
like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Jeff] So I study ice cores and I'm just
an armchair admirer of the people who
study evolution of humans. So I'm very
pleased to be invited here and I hope I
can contribute something. My outline is
that first I'll take a little sort of
digression away from the topic of human
evolution just to give you some background
on what's happening right now and how, for
example, do we know that humans are
causing the current climate change.
Then I'll talk about the observations made
by many other people, not myself, that
agriculture seems to have originated
precisely when we had the most recent of
these abrupt climate change events 11.7
thousand years ago. Some people call it
the end of the Younger Dryas period and
it's really quite a stunning coincidence
and it probably isn't a coincidence. Many
people now believe that the warming and
the wetting allowed humans to switch from
a hunting and gathering mode of existence
to an agricultural mode of existence.
Then I'll go on to talk about abrupt
climate change itself and what causes it.
To tell you the punch-line which is that
we think it's the switching on and off of
ocean circulation. I'll wrap up with the
question will it happen again in the
future?
So my little digression, the smoking gun
of human causation. I love this diagram
and you don't see it in the media very
often. I think it's a shame that we don't
because it really is a very powerful form
of evidence. If someone asks you if you
believe in global warming you should say
no because it's not a matter of belief
it's a matter of evidence.
This is from the ice cores. I'm proud to
say this is my field of ice core science.
We know from the bubbles trapped in ice
core that CO2 in the atmosphere was at
about 280 parts per million for most of
the last 1,000 years. Then right around
the time of major coal burning around 1850
it started to creep up. Here we are today
at 400 parts per million and at the same
time, this rare isotope of carbon that
Peter deMenocal introduced to you, Carbon
13 in the atmospheric CO2 changed from a
very stable value.
Don't worry about these units
and it started
taking a nose dive. That's the signature
of fossil fuel burning. If the CO2 was
coming from the ocean, which is the major
natural source of CO2, it would not have
done this. It would have been flat. So
this really is the smoking gun. You can
say that with great great confidence and
of course there are a lot of other lines
of evidence but I like this one in
particular.
The other thing that you can do if you're
confronted by someone who doesn't buy this
argument that CO2-- How do we know that
CO2 actually causes climate you can look
to our neighbor Venus, which has about
3,000 times more CO2 in its atmosphere
than our planet and it has a surface
temperature of 450 degrees centigrade,
which is hot enough to melt lead.
It's basically a combination of Venus,
basic physics that tell us that CO2 traps
heat and these undisputed measurements of
CO2 concentration in its isotopes. Those
three things taken together pretty much
sums it all up. Everything else is kind of
details.
We know that humans are embarking on a
dramatic future change of climate. It
doesn't really matter that much what's
happened up until now. I mean asking
whether the earth is warming or not is
kind of like driving towards a cliff and
asking are we dropping yet? It's really
not that interesting a question, actually.
While I'm on the topic of smoking guns,
this is a very famous picture that many
people have seen, the CO2 concentration
from ice cores and here we are today at
400. So you see it is quite unusual in the
context of the last 800,000 years which is
the whole ice core record. I'm working on
trying to extend this back to 1.5 million
years. You can ask me about that later if
you want.
The important thing about this that this
is not the smoking gun of human causation.
There's been an awful lot of confusion
about this. Al Gore, bless his heart, I
think kind of led us down the wrong path
by implying this was some kind of evidence
that CO2 causes climate change. In fact
it's mostly the other way around that
Antarctic temperature is related to the
things that control natural variations in
the CO2.
The current CO2 spike has nothing to do
with these variations. It's not coming
from the ocean as you saw from the Carbon
13 evidence; it's coming from fossil
fuels. It's a completely different
chemical in fact. If somebody gives you a
hard time about the fact that the CO2
changes slightly after the temperature,
you can tell them that's expected because
it's natural CO2 and it's responding to
climate, it's not causing climate.
And the related myth is that the ice core
record that you've just seen shows that
carbon dioxide rose after temperature
began warming at the ends of ice ages.
Which is true that's why it's in black.
Ergo, carbon dioxide does not cause
warming which is false. The fact is that
ice ages are ended by the changes in the
earth's orbit as you heard earlier today.
So it's not surprising that the
temperature changes first and you can
think of CO2 as a feedback that amplifies
the initial warming by about 30% probably.
It's not actually a huge increase. It's
maybe two degrees bigger of a change than
you would have gotten otherwise. So humans
are adding CO2 directly to the atmosphere
and so ice ages are not a good analog,
it's a red herring.
I couldn't resist showing this because
it's such a nice analogy. If you overspend
your credit card, you go into debt, and
then you have to pay interest, right. Then
it makes more debt. So interest lags debt.
How do we know that interest adds to debt?
We can't explain the total size of the
debt without taking into account interest
and also economics.
Tells us in the climate of the past now.
We have the earth's orbit causing warming,
making CO2 rise as the ocean warms and out
gases, CO2, and then causes further
warming as an amplifier. So that's the
whole end of story about human caused
climate change. Now I'm going to move on
into this idea that the first evidence for
agriculture was seen during this abrupt
warming.
This is a fascinating topic and it's
mostly, I think, the work of Brian Baird
who used to be here at UCSD. Who
discovered that the very first
domesticated plants, I think they were
barley seeds, actually, occur within plus
or minus 200 years of this abrupt warming
event right here. Seen, this is actually
the Greenland temperature, but it's a lot
of the northern hemisphere European
temperature as well.
Then this is a methane record from the ice
core and it seems to be a proxy for
wetness. There's a great deal of increase
in northern hemisphere low latitude
rainfall at this time. This all happened
in about 30 years. These are very fast
events. There's about half of the
temperature change seems to have occurred
in one year.
These are the kinds of things that could
impose very large stresses on humans
potentially because there's not enough
time to adapt. What's amazing about this
is that people seem to have completely
changed in a very short time their mode of
existence from hunting and gathering to
farming right here.
It's probably because everything got so
much warmer and wetter that it was just
really lush. Think about the Garden of
Eden. That's probably sometime in here. We
don't know whether it was 8,000 years or
12,000 years, whatever. That was an
example of abrupt climate change that
probably greatly benefited our ancestors.
Of course when it's cooling, it's drying
as well and that would be a period of
intense stress. There were probably
population bottle-necks at the time and
those may be very important for evolution.
Because if you kill off 97% of the humans
then you just leave 3%, those will have
characters that will then be able to
spread widely without having to exchange
with a large gene pool.
So you can get very powerful evolutionary
change through this bottlenecks and what's
remarkable about this abrupt events is
they happen again and again. It's not just
one of them it's 25 of them in the last
100,000 years and probably something like
20 in the 100,000 years before that.
All told, our ancestors probably went
through at least 100 of these bottlenecks.
So it's a repeated form of boom and bust
and William Calvin had a very nice book
about this kind of boom and bust
evolutionary pumping hypothesis.
I'm going to switch now to talk about the
physical science understanding that we
have about abrupt climate change. What
causes it in the first place and as I
hinted at the beginning it's something to
do with ocean circulation. Warm water at
the surface in the north Atlantic is
carried by currents to this place around
Greenland where it becomes cold and dense
enough to sink.
Then it travels southwards along the
bottom of the ocean and what these seems
to do is that it actually displaces the
earth's thermal equator north of the
geographic equator. The northern
hemisphere today is quite a bit warmer
than the southern hemisphere.
We believe that from theory and evidence
that this circulation is capable of
shutting off. So that's what a cooling is
and when it turns back on that's what an
abrupt warming is. This is kind of what
the Paleo records look like of this
phenomena of turning on and shutting off
the north Atlantic circulation.
In the northern records you see abrupt
warmings at the times when the circulation
goes on. In the southern hemisphere, this
is Antarctica, you actually see a gradual
warming during times when the north is
cold and then an inflection point towards
gradual cooling in the south. This is very
strong evidence that this really is the
ocean circulation.
This is from a very recent ice core we
drilled that just finished and we got
published in Nature a few weeks ago. This
is one of the main findings from this ice
core is that because we can now date the
two hemispheres relative to each other to
a precision of about 50 years. We can show
that the northern abrupt warming leads the
southern transition to cooling which is
shown here by about 200 years.
That's very interesting because that
really confirms that this is the ocean
circulation that is doing this. I think
it's the latest in a long line of pieces
of evidence that support the notion that
it is this ocean circulation sort of
oscillating and flipping on and off that
does this.
Will it happen again in the near future?
Is an abrupt climate change something we
have to worry about? Well you may have
seen the movie The Day After Tomorrow.
It's something that is permeated into the
public consciousness but I think the
answer is probably not.
The reason I say that is that the Atlantic
Ocean is getting saltier today. In the
last 50 years it's increased its salinity
dramatically. You can sort of see that in
this cartoon here. The Atlantic is all
yellow which is an increase in salinity.
The Pacific has a lot of blue and that
means a sort of decrease in salinity.
So what's going on right now is that the
Atlantic is getting saltier. The Pacific
is getting fresher and that's exactly what
we expect to happen in a warming world
because warm air holds more water vapor.
So it's impossible to transport more vapor
out of the Atlantic into the Pacific
across Panama as you see here.
Basically whenever the world gets warmer
the Atlantic gets saltier. The salt
actually densifies the water, makes it
easy to sink and it actually protects that
circulation. While there was some worry
maybe 15 years ago that the Atlantic
circulation would shut down due to global
warming. I think we can say now we've
learned something, science moves on. It is
now very unlikely this will happen again.
The other thing of course is that we don't
have the amplifying factor of sea ice. Sea
ice makes the ocean turn from dark to
white. So it greatly exacerbates the
effects of the overturning circulation
shutting off.
My take home messages. I hope I have
convinced you that abrupt climate change
did stimulate farming and there's a very
very interesting story that's only just
beginning to be understood. It's very
probable that many many abrupt climate
changes prior to this one that stimulated
farming, played a role by creating
bottlenecks that made the survivors of
this event able to radiate out into an
empty niche after the event.
Very probably I think, also, encouraged
people who could do things differently
than their parents were doing them. As I
have some kids who are becoming teenagers
I know a lot about this sort of
oppositional, don't do what your parents
were doing kind of stuff and I just wonder
if maybe the teenager kind of thing has
its origins in abrupt climate change.
Because if your parents are telling you to
eat fruit and the climate just crashed and
you say I do things differently than my
parents. I'm going to eat roots instead of
fruits. Well you might be the one who
actually survives because you're a root
eater. I'm just wondering maybe this
population bottlenecks somehow encouraged
sort of contrarian thinking.
Atlantic Ocean overturning circulation is
the culprit, I think. We can now say that
causes abrupt climate change. Will it
happen? Again in the future probably not.
That's one thing we can breathe easier
about. Check that one off the list. More
salt less sea ice in our future. Thank
you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [William] This is kind of this
transition talk between the relatively
deep past and the very recent past and
present and future. There is a debate
going on about this. I'm talking about the
last 10,000 years when agriculture
developed. There is a debate going on or a
discussion going on in the community.
If you asked the average geo-scientist are
humans now in control of the world, the
atmosphere, the water, the soil,
everything else. I think you would get
pretty much a 100% response yes. The
debate or discussion is about whether to
define a particular time when that began.
On that, there is less unanimity. I am
somewhat towards one extreme of that
argument.
I was asked to write a perspective piece
in Science. This is not the most exciting
slide in the world, but you can at least
read the title. It's about this discussion
about defining this epoch we leave in.
Whether to do it in a very recent time and
there's a proposal out from a group in
London, geologists, [inaudible 00:19:57]
to make it the 1945
and 1950 era because all kinds of things
started to happen that humans hadn't been
doing before then and because bomb testing
began then and these isotopes that people
have been talking about were spread widely
in the ocean, ocean sediments and in ice
cores.
There's a move to say that anthropocene,
the start of the human domination of the
planet, is in the 1950s. This slide shows
a dark colored bar down the right center
part which defines that. It actually chose
the industrial era which is the last 200
years and there's substantial support for
this suggestion to do this. However, those
of us who work back on somewhat longer
time scales favor a longer interval of
human influence on the earth.
Extending back about 10,000 years to the
earliest major domestication and dispersal
of crops and livestock and a series of
things that happened and accelerated since
that time. So that's what I'm going to
talk about. I'm going to take you back
10,000 years and tell you what we were up
to as we became agricultural people.
There's been a community since.
This is kind of a cartoon version that I
drew about five or six years ago of the
little figure that's on the right insert
on your program and its pretty close, it's
a schematic. You notice that nice wrinkle
in the deglaciation points here. Coming
from glacial cold temperatures up into the
modern interglacial warmth, it peaks out
then it starts to decline very slightly
towards the present. Now we're taking off
into worlds unknown with the industrial
revolution.
This is the picture of climate for the
last 20,000 years that prevailed through
the 1900s right to the turn of the
century. Here's a picture, that I think is
correct, you notice it's the same from the
glacial cold era coming up into the
warmth.
But around 8,000 years ago in this slide
something else starts to happen. You see
agriculture originating at the bottom of
the slide and agriculture produces
greenhouse gas effects. There's no
disagreement about that but there's a big
disagreement about how much the amplitude
of these greenhouse gas effects.
The proposal is that these anthropogenic
greenhouse gases kept the climate from
getting as cold as it would have without
the gases. That in fact early farming
stopped nature from taking us back into
the beginnings of a new glaciation
sometime in the last maybe 2,000 or 3,000
years. So early farming stopped the
glaciation.
It sounds radical, but I'll take you
through the steps. There are two ways to
think about this. These are greenhouse
gases that are recorded in ice cores as
you have already learned. Air in the ice
cores preserves the amount of greenhouse
gases and here are two examples of these.
The red dots show for methane at the top
carbon dioxide at the bottom. Those are
the values during the last 11,000 years,
that time scale along the bottom, and you
see them both peaking, methane and carbon
dioxide, peaking about 10,000 years ago
starting to decrease and then climbing.
Carbon dioxide comes back up after about
6,000 years ago. Methane comes back up
after about 5,000 years ago. Also plotted
on this slide in dark blue circles is an
average of the seven previous
interglaciations and you've seen that they
were about every 100,000 years. There was
interglacial climate due to those
variations in earth's orbit.
You see that starting with methane.
There's a peak in methane about the same
time as the red circles for this
interglaciation. Then there is a decrease
not dissimilar to this interglaciation but
then instead of turning on and going up
this average of all seven previous
interglaciations keep going down. The same
thing happens for CO2 with an even more
striking match of the current
interglaciation and the average of the
previous interglaciations and they part
ways about 6,000 ago.
I call this top-down evidence for human
influence and the way to think about it is
really simple. If the blue circles show
previous interglaciations when no one
thinks humans are having massive effects
on this environment or its atmosphere. If
blue is natural and if blue is going down
then red is not natural. So something new
is working in this interglaciation.
I say what humans are doing 6,000 years
ago starts to push the CO2 curve upward
and starts to push the methane upward
about 5,000 year ago. Anomalous and I say
anthropogenic factor is at work. I call
that a top down view because it's from the
point of view of the atmosphere and that's
half of a hypothesis. If you want a full
hypothesis you need bottom-up evidence.
What's happening on the ground? What are
people actually up to?
This slide is a very simplified version of
the spread of agriculture. You can see
here I'm mapping mainly the spread not the
initial domestication of crops and
livestock. You can see in southwest Asia,
the eastern Mediterranean after about
9,000 years ago crops which originated in
the fertile crescent started to spread
across Europe came down to the Nile River
valley went east into Pakistan and India.
About the same time in northern China,
people domesticated crops and animals and
that spread beginning of the Han dynasty.
The Han people, I should say, spread up
into Korea and then in the rest of China.
Then around 5,000 years ago in southern
China the development of irrigated rice
spreads across down into India, down into
Southeast Asia and the Philippines. Those
are major centers of domestication.
Around 5,000 years ago, the Bantu people
in the tropical North Africa and
Sub-Saharan Africa developed sufficiently
impressive agriculture that they spread
all across southern Africa except for
South Africa itself. One of the major
migrations of human history.
Over in the Americas in Mexico even though
agriculture began earlier by 4,000 years
ago the combination of corn, beans,
avocados and tomatoes people were
spreading agriculture up into North
America and down through Central America.
Finally in the eastern Andes part of the
Amazon more agriculture beginning there
4,000 years ago. All of these are
happening during the time when those
greenhouse gas trends were going the wrong
way.
To go back at the methane curve shown at
the top. Remember their departure is 5,000
years ago. Here's a map of the spread of
rice agriculture through Asia. It
originates in the Yangtze river valley and
by 5,000 years ago rice is fully
domesticated. It spreads down across the
rest of Asia by 1,000 years ago. This
based on Archeo-botanical work.
Rice paddies are manmade wetlands and
wetlands are basically swamps which have
swamp gas which has methane which bubbles
out of the rice paddies. The spread of
rice agriculture coincides nicely with the
reversal of the methane trend. The man who
did this was Dorian Fuller at University
College London,
converted that the spread of rice and then
assumed in filling of the density of rice
into estimates of total rice area.
Irrigated that's in green and he converted
that using modern relationship estimates
of the effect on atmospheric methane.
He got a 70 parts per billion estimate
between 5,000 and 1,000 years ago.
The ice core data which I showed you
earlier shows 100 parts per billion. So if
his estimate's right and they're going to
be more versions of this I'm sure, rice
irrigation would explain 70% of the rise
of the methane trend. Remember also the
full anomaly also would include the fact
that the methane trend should have gone
down but it didn't so there's more to
explain.
Dorian Dorian
Fuller also mapped the spread of livestock
across Africa and Asia. You see that
between 7,000 and 5,000 years ago the
livestock are in relatively arid areas.
The Sahara which is greener, it has
grasslands because it's getting some
moisture. The Iranian plateau and western
China. But between 5,000 and 1,000 years
ago livestock spreads all the way across
India and eastern Asia and down into South
Africa with that Bantu migration.
There will be estimates of the methane
contributions from livestock, too, and
they will explain more of the anomaly.
Carbon dioxide at the bottom until
recently has been very tricky for a number
of reasons which I can't go into in this
talk, but there's been an explosion of
data in the last three or four years that
bears on this.
Now to get carbon dioxide from farming you
need to clear trees and burn them or just
let them rot which puts the CO2 in the
atmosphere. There's a map of the spread of
agriculture across Europe beginning in the
lower right in the fertile crescent and
spreading all the way to the far reaches
of Europe by 5,500 years ago. Interesting
point 5,500 years ago is still the late
Neolithic, the late Stone-age. We don't
even have Bronze Age tools, but people are
coming in and clearing forests. They're
using very sophisticated flint axes.
There is agriculture all across Europe by
5,500 years ago which is that CO2 curve
starts to rise by 6,500. That doesn't
begin to prove that deforestation explains
the carbon dioxide rise, but a paper
published earlier this year certainly
points in that direction. The top left
panel shows the synthesis of hundreds of
lake cores that have pollen remains which
include remains of grass pollen, tree
pollen and then intermediate pollen that's
shrubs and things that are in between.
If you look at the trend in part B, the
dark green forest pollen starts to
decrease somewhere between 6,000 and 5,000
years ago which is just after that carbon
dioxide curve starts to turn up and go the
wrong way. Before you get to the
industrial era, you've basically gotten
rid of the forest. This is favorable to an
early anthropogenic effect, a large early
anthropogenic effect and as the top right
slide shows it's based on hundreds of
cores.
Part C and D show some data from China.
Not pollen data, but numbers of
archeological sites. It turns out that
the Chinese government for decades has
been funding people to gather information
on the impressive early history of China.
There's just thousands and thousands of
archeological data points. Either radio
carbon dated or correlated by cultural
remains to other sequences that are dated.
The bottom left slide shows the number of
archeological sites 8,000 to 7,000 years
ago. They are mostly down in the Yellow
river valley and they're fairly sparse. By
5,000 to 4,000 years ago they Yellow river
valley's just completely filled in. There
were people burning coal in some of these
areas because the forest is gone and it's
coming down into the Yangtze river valley.
This is before that rice spread begins in
southern China and the rest of Asia.
I guess I can summarize by saying in the
last three or four years there's been an
explosion of ground truth evidence that
people are doing things that are putting a
lot of methane and carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere.
This is beginning to gather some attention
from those who report the scientific news.
This is from Science autumn 2013. This is
a piece that the commentary focused on
methane and you can read the title and get
the punch-line yourself.
Here's a paper that was published, a
features piece, that was published in the
other
most distinguished journal, that's Nature.
The central panel shows the time of major
cultural effects on land clearance and
vegetation. You see that there are blocks
there that are dating back to 5,000 years
or more. You also see that methane
reversal plotted in the curve at the
bottom right.
As we go off in the next few talks after
the break into talking about the major
things that have happened during the
industrial revolution and during the last
50 years. Keep in mind that we have a long
history of affecting climate and the scope
of it is still coming into focus but it's
coming into focus pretty fast. I think
humans have been a major factor in the
landscape for thousands of years not just
200 years.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Charles] I am in fact literally the
bridge between the past and the future in
many different ways. This is the title
that I originally chose when I submitted
my first abstract. But as I got to
preparing it, I thought I would try
something new with the same material that
I've been working on for some time. I have
rechanged the name now: Anatomy of a
Climate Regime Change.
It's the same material, basically, but the
hypothesis is that we may be with our
modern instrumentation over the last 20 or
so years. We may be seeing a change in
climate that is something like those that
might have caused Jeff Severinghaus'
abrupt transitions. I'm going to go
through it with you. It is of course a
very small version of very big events that
happened in the past.
I first got interested in this problem
because of an issue of public awareness
and policy. The public issue is called the
paradox that triples the hiatus paradox.
If you cherry pick your data as this
article did, you can find a time in 1997
and another time in 2012 when the earth's
temperature was the same that it had been.
This led to the idea that the globe is not
warming even though the carbon dioxide is
increasing.
I began to ask myself two other questions.
What else was going on while the global
temperature was constant? Was climate
change also disappearing? I found of
course two other paradoxes. Why are the
extreme events in climate increasing?
Here's the key I chose why is the Arctic
warming even more rapidly?
Let's first of all verify that this is the
hiatus. It started in the year 2000 and
during that time the carbon dioxide has
increased and humans have added about 27%
more CO2 than they have since the
beginning of the industrial revolution.
This should have led to an increase in the
warming rate in climatologist language of
four tenths of a watt per meter. We were
putting more energy into climate but it
wasn't turning up in the global
temperature. The question was where was
that energy going?
So here's a longer perspective on the
hiatus. This is a record since 1880 and it
shows a much shorter record than you've
seen this far but it shows the global
temperature evolution. The first thing you
notice is that there was another hiatus
between '45 and '75. They do happen; they
are features of climate models. They are
areas where the climate goes through a
reconfiguration.
Our present hiatus started with a bang.
With a huge El Niño in 1997 and '8. My
first year as director of Scripps where my
office was inundated. Then you can see the
profile of the slowly warming that we've
seen throughout this century.
Now the global mean temperature that the
scientists calculate is taken from data
and most of it is from satellite
observations of the sea surface
temperature. The sea covers 70% of the
earth's surface. So you would expect that
this computation will be dominated by
what's happening in the ocean.
After After
many gyrations, the community came to
realize that it was the behavior of the
ocean that was responsible for this hiatus
in warming. Because we knew from earlier
studies going back to the 1980s that
Pacific Ocean for example oscillate
between two very extreme states in which
the temperature changes dramatically.
You'll notice that El Niño is a warm state
and La Niña is a cool state. So perhaps
what was happening was that we were
switching from El Nino to La Niña a
prevailing state thereof. I have to tell
you just a little bit about how the El
Niño cycle works.
So what you're looking at here is a
picture taken from the sketch taken from
the Pacific equator. Stretching from the
east in Lima to the west in Darwin and
you'll see at the top in the La Niña
phrase the trade winds pushed the wavy
ocean towards the west. That water heats
up from the sun as it goes and as it heats
up it expands a little bit so the winds
have to push the water upstream, uphill.
It goes until it can't go any further. So
you get deep water in the western Pacific
that's warm and then the circulation
pattern pushes up cold water in the east.
That's the cooling phase of La Niña.
The El Niño is a little bit different. The
trade winds can suddenly stop for some
reason and then all this water rushes
downhill and the warm water gets heated a
second time as it crosses the Pacific and
you slosh up against the North American
and South American continents.
What happened? Did the trade winds
increase and were of the right sense to
create an El Niño, a La Niña? The answer
is from this remarkably difficult data set
to compile 100 years of the trade wind
stress on the ocean water in the central
Pacific. You can see it oscillated around
until about the year 2000 when it switched
from El Niño sense smaller trade wind to
La Niña sense larger trade wind.
It's continuing to get larger in the
negative direction. That's the negative
part of this curve and it's
unprecedentedly large and it is not
included at present in contemporary
climate models. But the trade wind has
been exceptionally large. Which means,
then, you would think if that were the
case that in fact you were driving a lot
of heat energy into the ocean in the
western Pacific.
Here is a picture of ocean heat content
that was published just about six or seven
months ago in Science but it looks like it
solves the problem. What Chen and Tang did
was divide their time that they looked at
the data from before the hiatus on the
right and after the hiatus began on the
left.
You see two plots. The bottom one is the
one pertinent to my argument about the El
Niño and I'll come to the top one in a
moment. What you see is a spread against
longitude across the Pacific. The red blob
is the distribution of ocean heat down to
about 300 meters. You see this abrupt
switch in color, s if you will, the same
switch that you saw in that earlier
picture from Woodshall.
What we do know is that at around the time
of the hiatus, the Pacific Ocean's state
changed to a heat sequestering state. But
the other thing that happened which
actually took over after a while during
this same period is displayed in this plot
on the left. Which is somewhat different
because it's a transect up the Atlantic
from south to north and it shows you where
new heat is being buried in the north
Atlantic.
You can see basically that the heat is
being buried at pretty high latitudes.
This started at approximately the same
time. This little event here we are
observing is a small version of the events
that Jeff Severinghaus was talking about
somewhat earlier. Where it was possible to
slow down the Atlantic meridian
circulation. You can see the strong
difference between the two states. This
change took place across the large El Niño
that started the process off.
So So
what else was going on during this time?
The oceans will tell you this spread all
around the earth's ocean and that tells
you right away that we're dealing with a
comprehensive change in ocean state. You
would expect then that there would be
other changes in the climate that occurred
at the same time, other parts of this
restructuring.
As you probably have understood from the
pictures of polar bears, there actually is
an Arctic regime shift in progress. This
was first revealed by two formal
assessments. One in 2005 that used
primarily data from before the hiatus
began and another one only seven years
later and they discovered a major change
in the distribution of Arctic heating.
During the hiatus it's been fastest in
spring and autumn and before it was
fastest in winter which was consistent
with the earlier greenhouse warming
models. It's now faster over the oceans
than the land. These change in patterns
suggested to you that the Arctic developed
a new warming source that was not as
strong in the previous period.
Satellite data first began to be collected
with great accurate data on Sea Ice area
in '79. Here is the curve that you can see
of the minimum Sea Ice extent which occurs
at the end of the warm season in
September. As a function of time September
after September since 1979.
What you can infer from this plot is a
break in behavior in which the sea ice was
slowly declining but oscillating about a
slowly declining mean. Suddenly there it
looks like a change in state and over this
period of time the sea ice area has
declined by about 40% and the sea ice
volume is down to 25% what it had been in
1979.
Here's the same data. That was there in
case the movie didn't work. That shows you
where the timing of the sea ice decline.
There's one other thing that has happened
during the period of the hiatus which I
think will be interesting to Jeff and
others. It's a small analog of the
events that slow the meridional
overturning circulation.
During this hiatus only since about the
year 2000 a new pattern of winds developed
over the Arctic Ocean. It's called the
Arctic Dipole Anomaly. This pair of winds
going in opposite direction drives ice and
sea and fresh water from the Arctic into
the north Atlantic where it will shut off
or it can impede. Where it collides,
basically, with the Gulf Stream and at
that collision point the water sinks to
depth and we did see that.
This is a small event of something that
actually happened in the historical record
8,000 years ago as the ice sheet was
retreating across North America. As it
retreated, it left behind in the area of
Hudson Bay a huge glacial lake that was
contained between the melting ice on one
hand and the moraine that pushed up on the
front. These glacial moraines are unstable
and there was a huge outflow of water that
occurred all at once and there was a 200
year period of cool climate that then
recovered.
The Columbia River was also formed this
way. What the satellites have observed is
a great injection of fresh water into this
Gyre here the Beaufort Gyre that began at
approximately the same time and that water
is lighter. When it gets to the saltier
Atlantic the saltier Atlantic will sink.
So here is the next and most important
point. This sea ice retreat that I just
documented is warming the Arctic by a very
simple mechanism. When you replace white
ice with blue ocean you absorb much more
solar energy. Sea ice itself may reflect
half back to space and the ocean absorbs
93% of the energy that's falling on it. As
the sea ice retreats, it warms the Arctic.
A recent paper that came out from Scripps
measured the degree of warming since the
satellite era started in '79 and they
found that the net sea ice retreat adds
about six watts per meter
squared, but two thirds of the heating
that took place in that period occurred in
those 10 years between '01 and '11. The
Arctic is small but if you average this
over the globe you get 0.21 watts per
meter squared which is about a quarter of
the increase that you would have expected
from the increase in greenhouse gas at
that time.
So you have added a new warning mechanism
that the climate, at least in recent
times, was not used to. This is a picture
of the geography of heat transport in the
climate and I put it on even though it's
complicated just to remind you that the
basic circulation of the atmosphere as
understood from the time of Edmond Halley
was there was heavy and strong warming of
the ocean and land over the tropics. This
heat was then transported to the north. So
it's a north south circulation-- north
equator to pole circulation that is the
fundamental feature of our climate
transport.
If you suddenly add a new heating source
at the poles particularly the Arctic won't
you change the circulation of heat in the
atmosphere? And will this not, in fact,
lead to states like the El Nino? What we
do know and this a question still under
active investigation, but what we do know
is that we have created a 17 or 18 year
persistent La Niña-like state in the
Pacific Ocean and also a similar outflow
in the north Atlantic that is lasting
longer than most typical La Niña's lasted
the whole period of time.
What this has had an effect on the climate
down below because when you're in a La
Niña state, you bend the jet stream as you
see and you've seen many many pictures
recently anytime you look at the weather
you'll see the jet stream dipping deep
into central United States. We've remained
in a state of La Niña-like jet stream. The
weather patterns, then, correlate with
this.
Now the question is the global
temperatures have been constant so you
would expect that there would be many
fewer heat waves or at least the same
number as before. This has not proven the
case. Here's a remarkable data analysis
generated in Spain. Where they were able
to compile the mean summer temperature in
Europe for the last 500 years since 1500.
What you see is five of the ten years in
the 2010 decade were the hottest years on
record.
You also hear about this unstable. You
hear this bending La Niña-like jet stream.
You hear about it in another context
because in the winter it brings Arctic air
to the south and it's then responsible for
the large snow storms that we've seen in
the past. We also know that the La Niña
state implies a very dry climate in
California, something that we are
presently observing.
Here are the questions. I phrased the
hypothesis at a set of questions. Did the
Arctic warming associated with super El
Niño, which pushed the ice over the edge,
did it trigger a continuing ice retreat
when winter regrowth could not make up for
the previous year's loss? Did Arctic
warming, by altering the north south heat
flow, did it strengthen the trade winds
create the La Niña bias, and enable the
persistent ocean heat sequestration that
we've been seeing?
Did it, warming, by altering the heat flow
cause the observed pattern enhancement of
extreme event occurrence? Then finally how
long can this kind of thing go on? Will
the present dynamical quasi-equilibrium be
maintained until the energy added to the
climate system from ice and snow retreat
stops? Thank you.
♪ [music] ♪